foreign
way down there holy hey buddy
what's your name
hey bud talk to me what's your name
he said I can't understand you
look at his tools over here
what is he doing
yeah
look kind of shady with no vehicles
around in the woods there's a couple of
tools yeah well here's a while
something's weird
yeah all right guys
when did you can you get his info real
quick did you find him okay
you're just the reporting party do you
know him
if you don't know him at all what he had
to be here for a couple days what
brought you guys over here I was fishing
and I've seen the lid open and I walked
past and I heard somebody it's like a
moon and I looked down and I'm like dude
are you all right
and I didn't see no ladder and that's
when he write up and called you guys how
long you been down there bud
told us three days three and a half days
yeah he opened it
I tossed this in the car
looked like he pried it open and
I mean I started looking around like I'd
say it backfired yeah
ladder
oh yeah oh yeah way down there
three and a half days yep we're gonna
have days
it would have to rain unfortunately
and then there's his tools right right
back there yeah he popped it open for
sure
question
shelter
foreign
[Music]
but one of them
it's hard to hear him
I think lieutenants were talking
yeah well there's a pry bar and a hammer
right there like I'm thinking he popped
it open and fell back down there
they were fishing yeah
yeah
I'm about to go get my blanket and just
put it over me
come out the wrong way but I you know
I'll give you a hug and wrap you around
I got a fire code what's wrong about
that
part is the best it gets all musty oh
yeah
I'm not even I don't put it but I'll get
that wool blanket out and I'll get
underneath it
yourself will get in your car like yeah
right
we're about to really get to know each
other
we're gonna be like what am I doing out
there in the rain I mean I can't do
nothing because
get the car get in your car
no don't get wet dude we're gonna be
here a while oh yeah yeah
they got to go get rescued and they got
a set of pry polish and everything to
get him out
thanks guys all right man
it's literally supposed to rain for like
15 minutes today and it would be right
now yeah
I'm gonna go ahead and go off huh
yeah get in your car stop recording